George papadopolis has a new book out
called deep state target how I got
caught in the crosshairs of the plot to
bring down president Trump probably the
most accurate title of a book in a long
time he joins us tonight George thanks
very much for coming on so briefly
describe your experience with the woman
you believe was sent to spy on the Trump
campaign by the Obama administration
sure that's a great question and I
received an unsolicited email in
September of 2016 from a man named
Stefan Hall / who I was suggesting that
he wanted to pay me $3,000 to write a
report on energy security questions that
I was a recognized expert on at the time
in Israel Turkey and Cyprus and I looked
him up I'd never heard of him before I
just saw that he had been he had worked
in for us administrations and he was a
professor at Cambridge so I accepted his
offer he flew me to London where he paid
a five-star hotel my flights and he said
before I meet with you I need you to
meet my assistant and he put this
assistant in an email chain along with
me and I saw her name was Asura Turk I
recognize it as Turkish which was a bit
suspicious right away because my policy
positions throughout my entire career
were very hostile to Turkey so when I
noticed the Turkish name I didn't
understand why she'd be involved but
anyways I went and I met with her and
she was very suggestive as you could
understand
younger you know very flirtatious and I
right away understood that this wasn't a
Cambridge assistant and you know she
barely spoke English he was very flirty
and was trying to do two things
one to extract information about my
professional connections in the Middle
East and two to see if I had any
information that she could potentially
extract for me about Trump in Russia
which of course is nonsense and so
anyways after I meet with her she is
then introduced to me again the next day
with Stefan helper where she goes from
this suggestive young lady to now
pouring us coffee and stuff on helpers
very belligerent I explained it in my
book on it how belligerent he is how he
invited me to basically castigate me
about my policy positions and of course
I was returned and took me to dinner
was just basically trying to extract
information I was very suspicious and
you know from that moment I knew there
was something wrong and I was laughing
about it but now of course the New York
Times reported that she was some sort of
agents but I don't think she was FBI I
think she was CIA but she was dispatched
by the Obama administration Barack Obama
was the president United States led the
executive branch including CIA and FBI
and every other agency to spy on in
effect the Trump campaign am I missing
something or is that is that what
happened that's absolutely what happened
and I and I want to make something very
clear here I don't think President Trump
was tweeting about UK interference out
of the blue for no reason last week
because let me explain why the day I met
with Stefan Halpern as rhetoric in
London I was invited by the British
Ministry of Foreign Affairs to meet with
them at their offices including with
Tobias Elwood
who was a number two at the time under
Boris Johnson so clearly when the New
York Times suggested in their reporting
today that the British were were told of
this operation I believe the British
actually were actively spying on me as
well and I think part of what President
Trump was tweeting last week about the
British spying was about this
involvement in this operation in London
so I guess where we have a lot more to
find out I would just reminder of you I
mean you went to put in jail briefly
correct yes I did I went for 11 nights
aw yeah so you got it you go to jail you
didn't spy for Russia it turns out you
didn't do anything wrong
and your life is destroyed but we
shouldn't figure out how this happened
because why I don't know George we
definitely need to find out yeah thank
yes I think we do and your book is a
good way to start that process thanks
for joining us tonight
George thanks for having me thanks a lot
for have me Tucker thank you of course